hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel
i'm back and uh i've decided to show you
one of the games from the tournament
that is currently happening the ultibox
norway championship i
thought about uh skipping the entire
event uh but this is one
game that you simply don't skip and i'm
sure you all know what i'm talking about
i'm sure you've all seen it
uh but uh just in case some of you
haven't uh let's check it out so it's
young shisht of duda versus magnus
carlson from round five
uh of the ultibox norway championship
and it's uh
well it's quite the game uh i know that
you guys are
have have are having a lot of question
about how everything went how the
surgery went it went great
as i i am here and you know i have i
haven't improved uh
well yeah we could say an an improved
heart valve and
and and improve the aorta and
should be working much much better i
should be i should not
be getting as tired as much i should be
able to to do much more
uh but we'll see how it goes so far i'm
more than pleased with the results and
if uh you know
uh on the upper side if i say some
nonsense i can always blame it on the
anesthesia
and this is one of the games that that i
knew i'm going to cover so i've been
home for some uh four days now uh
that i've returned from the hospital and
i feel i feel confident enough to try
and make a video i still don't know if
i'm actually gonna upload it but
i'm just gonna try and make it so
without further ado let's check it out
round five of the outbox ultibox norway
championship
youngshish of duda versus magnus carlsen
uh let's see what happens here so do
that with the white pieces
opens with e4 we have c6 by magnus going
for the karo khan defense
uh we have d4 and d5 sorry about that
uh we have knight to c3 so just the
normal standard karo khan uh
the characters on e4 knight captures and
now knight to f6
we have captures on f6 this is all
perfectly standard e
captures and now c3 strengthening the
center
we have bishop to d6 and now bishop to
d3
with castles by magnus and the queen to
c2 now so inviting rook to e8
check but it's not a problem uh there is
a lot of theory regarding this so rookie
check
and now there are only a handful of
games with the bishop to e3 even though
it's not a mistake or anything it's like
the second
the engine second move uh but since this
is a a variation from the age of the
engines
everyone plays the the the first move
recommended by the engine so knights to
e2
uh and h5 by magnus uh we have bishop to
e3
continuing development and knight to d7
and do the castle's queen side
and there are a lot of moves that uh are
possible here knight to f8 is the
the most popular one uh uh releasing
that
grip grip of the bishop on f5 uh but
here we have b5 instead magnus starts
pushing right away
and this is where things get really
interesting so here duda continues with
d5 he puts pressure on the position uh
because he's either going to capture on
c6 or if magnus captures or advances
he's going to capture on b5 and
black's pawn structure will be uh will
become very vulnerable
so here magnus uh continues with what he
had in mind he
he he decided to go for his pawn
sacrifice he played c5
and he gives up the b5 pawn and okay
dude says i will i will have that pawn
uh we have bishop captures on b5 and now
rook to b8
attacking the bishop here uh c4 nicely
defending and now a6
opening up the b file for carlson's rook
and here
bishop to a4 and this is where the
things get uh
well different there is one game in the
database where rook the e5 was played
uh in the puerto cara open uh velimir
which played it against torbjorn henson
and it was it was quite the game uh but
here
instead of uh rook to e5 we have rook to
e7
and here uh it is as of move 15 that we
have a completely new game
so let's see how dude that deals with
this he says okay that's a bit different
now i'm going to play knights to g3
which attacks your pawn here but also uh
threatens uh
not that uh knight to f5 which will go
after the rook and the bishop here so
magnus says okay i'm gonna go knight if
95 now the bishop guards the square
so knight to e4 capturing here doesn't
really do all that much
uh because bishop g4 just gets the job
done for black
so instead knights the e4 uh an
excellent
square for the knight you will be able
to capture the bishop
[Music]
as soon as you want and if the bishop
moves you will be able to
push your past pawn so here rook eat the
b7 this was carlson's plan all along he
shifts both of his rooks to the open b
file middle uh middle is uh
sniffing around uh some some some areas
that he shouldn't be sniffing around at
uh but okay uh rook e to b7 and now b3
defending the b2 pawn of course we have
b3 and now
rook to b4 and this is where things get
really interesting you can see
already that there are some tactics here
like for example rook capture here
upon captures then the other rook takes
this rook's place and then rook captures
on c4 might be an idea
because the knight also covers c4 the
queen and king are here
so could be a lot of nasty stuff
happening and
duda has to decide what to how to go
about this does he go for bishop
captures on d6
or does he go the other way around which
is bishop to d2
and uh try and force this variation
which is what he does he goes bishop to
d2
and magnus decides to go for rook
captures on a4
so b captures on a4 and now bishop to f5
and this is a very very interesting
position uh this bishop completely
controlling this diagonal which is
beautiful the root controlling the b
file uh dudas king stuck on c1 uh it's
uh it's pretty pretty crazy magnus
sacrificed material but he does have the
bishop air he does have the attack
so let's see what happens so do that
goes to rook d to e1
a very important move as you also need a
safety square for your king you don't
want to constantly be worried about
what if the the queen moves and then i
get checkmated
and here we have h4 by magnus knight to
g4
was also an idea but knight to g4 is
basically if you want to
trade back the material you've
sacrificed for example now you're
threatening this
captures followed by knight captures on
f2 for example f3
uh you could go capture through captures
and still knight f2 will win you back
your rook so if you want you could go
for this but magnus
goes for something else he goes for h4
first
uh with h3 by duda not allowing to
create further weaknesses because if you
allow h3
then this is weak then this is coming in
it's uh is just terrible
uh but as you can see here it's it's uh
it's a difficult position to play for
for white uh if you put this position to
an engine uh the
uh the engine will tell you that white
white is better but
imagine playing this i mean you can't
move anything you can't move the queen
you can't move the knight
uh you constantly have to worry about
the the queen entering uh
into the position if the queen moves
somewhere it's a it's a pretty crazy
position
so here like i said h3 and now knight to
g6 by magnus
now uh uh now the knight can come
even deeper into the game so here rook
to e3 it's a very important move
as it brings the rook into the game and
it allows the bringing of the other rook
into the game as well plus you have some
additional protection along the third
rank
knights to f4 by magnus and now comes g4
so attacking the bishop here magnus just
moves that he's not interested in
capturing alpha song
and now comes king to d1 by duda
getting the king to a slightly safer
square so you don't have to constantly
be
uh worried about any any united jumps in
the future
uh but here uh magnus uh played
f5 queen to d7 is a sort of a prelude to
f5 and
it was the way to go but he played f5 a
bit too
bit too soon and here duda had a free
move
so here duda played knight captures on
d7 we have queen captures on d7 and now
g captures on f5 so he closes this
diagonal
uh well i'm not gonna say uh forever but
for a very long time bishop h5 check and
now
f3 as the rook covers the f3 square
and here magnus goes in with queen to f6
and here you have some
very very interesting options the queen
can go to a1 uh
the rook is still very strong the
knight's still very strong the bishop is
still very active
so it's still very interesting but
comparing it to this position before f5
was played
uh duda had a lot less resources um
at his disposal so queen to f6 magnus
throws the queen into the game and now
of course you don't want to allow
any backracks it checks so bishop the c3
now ideas like rook g1 are coming uh so
of course you have to prevent that but a
queen to g5
uh defending g1 also threatening some
discoveries as the rook on e3 is
undefended
so instantly uh queen e4 rook
h31 also gets uh gets the rook into the
game while defending this rook but duda
prefers queen to e4
and here queen the g2 now magnus offers
the knight for the rook here
rook h to e1 and now now f6
is the way to to properly defend with
black although it's
very very hard to decide how to how to
even do such a thing in such a position
uh for example f6 you have to realize
that if the knight is captured
uh yes you are attacking this guy here
but also
rook to b1 is just checkmate so that's
that's the thing
uh so that's why uh f6 is a strong
defensive resource here but magnus
played queen captures on a2 which seems
like
it wins the game on the spot uh because
i mean how do you prevent uh rook to b1
there's just no move that prevents that
or or is there uh well uh feel free to
pause the video and
try to figure out if there is such a
move indeed in this position
while i give you a couple of seconds
uh so uh for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on spotting the
only winning move for white
uh in the position and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
uh it's queen to c2 and it's just
incredible that
such a move uh you know uh shows up out
of nowhere
because now your original idea doesn't
really work rook b1 check you just move
the king king to d2
and now i mean your queen is hanging
where you move the queen because the
rook will be hanging as well
so we might as well trade everything and
after all is said and done captures
captures is
you're just up a piece you have more
pawns you're completely winning
another thing you could do after this
queen to c2 idea is
just go queen captures and c2 right away
but i mean
you you've already sacrificed material
you can't uh you can't continue like
this
so queen captures on c4 is what magnus
played
but this comes with the sacrifice of
more material
so rook to e8 check by do that now king
the h7 not even allowing this trade to
happen
uh now asking do you want to capture on
ba to do that says yeah i'm not afraid
rook captures on b8 was played
and now uh bishop captures an f3 very
interesting for magnus but it doesn't do
anything because after king c1 knight e3
check
you can just play king b1 now it's a
duda's rook that controls the entire b
file you don't really you don't have a
continuation here
so after this rook captures on b8 move
we have queen captures on d5 again with
check for magnus queen to d2 blocking
now with an attack on the knight and
now bishop captures on f3 with check
king to c1
and now queen captures on f5 so magnus
grabs that pawn as well
and now rook to e3 so magnus is still
kind of attacking but uh duda has two
rooks and if
if magnus doesn't figure out something
out uh like instantly it's uh
it's going to be over for him so knight
the e2 wit check
uh hoping that uh hoping the dude of
course captures this so you have some
queen f4 check action at the end picking
up the rook there
however after 92 check just king b2 by
duda
and now knight captures on c3 by magnus
we have queen captures on c3 attacking
the bishop and now
queen to f4 offering the bishop for the
rook there
uh queen to d3 checked by duda and now
f5
still the rook is under attack so rook
to f8 and now threatening to pick up the
f pawn
and queen to be for width check we have
king to c1 and now
bishop to e4 so magnus
is able to create this uh this uh well
barricade here as now the bishop and
pawn
uh will be will be guarding the black
king somewhat from the two rooks but
for how long uh queen to b3 again
offering a trade of queens magnus of
course has no option he has to decline
and the queen to c3 again offering that
queen trade queen back to d6 and now
rook to f7 here dude is a threatening
checkmate and
there's not all that much uh magnus can
do here queen g6 defending uh
rook to d7 now we have
queen to g1 magnus has to try something
king to b2 and
now uh c4 again magnus try some trickery
here
uh because uh well if you go if you go
for the capture here then
you just hang a rook here so instead
after c4 we have
rook captures on e4 dude that says okay
i'm up so much material i really don't
care anymore i just want to get
this done so f captures an e4 and now
rook to d4 dude is up a whole rook and
uh
well if this was any other normal game
rather than the one that had carlson's
150 games winning streak on the line i'm
sure magnus would have resigned
uh long ago but of course he continues
queen f2 check we have queen to d2
defending and now c3 with check uh
captures and now queen to g3 with check
at least
you cannot capture here so magnus will
create another pass pawn
king to b2 and now queen captures on h3
duda also grabs the e4 pawn
we have queen to g3 and now queen to d4
we have queen to g2 check magnus still
hoping to promote his pass pawn
king to c3 and now queen to f3 again
with check we have king to b4 and now
quinta f8
with check king to a5 and now queen to
f5
with check king captures on a6 and now
g5 no no longer is there any time for
for waiting around uh magnus just opens
up the position and he will start
pushing his pawns
but i mean the reality is he is down the
rook
so a5 uh but h3 also magnus starts
pushing
rook the e7 check kinked the g6 and now
queen the g7 with check by duda king h5
and now queen to h7 check
connecting nicely here uh magnus still
goes king to g4
so hoping for a queen trade maybe he can
start pushing his two connected past
pawns
it's not not much but something to go on
uh however uh
feel free to pause the video and end
this game and with it carlson's
150 games unbeaten streak while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it uh of course the move is
rook to e for check congratulations to
everyone and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
that's the move uh and here it was in
this position of course that magnus
calls and resigned again because you can
either
capture the rook which means you you're
going to be down a whole queen
or you're going to move your own king
from the defense of the queen and then
just captures and
that's just it so yeah uh what uh what a
way to go it was it was a brilliant run
i was uh for those of you who don't
remember last time magnus lost the game
was two years two months and ten days
ago
uh to shakh in the bill chess festival
and now he loses uh to
young [ __ ] of duda in round five of the
ultibox norway championship
so pretty crazy stuff uh just uh one of
the games i wanted to show you i didn't
know if i was going to make any videos
from this tournament or how i was going
to feel after
the operation and everything but i
i i must say i feel incredibly
incredibly well
i didn't think i'd be feeling that great
and that uh my
recovery would be going so well but uh
you know seems like uh
seems like uh care in croatia is like
top notch or something
because you know they they really did a
fine job
uh and yeah now if any of you guys have
any questions regarding this i don't
want to talk too much about
the the operation but if you guys are
interested in that just drop a comment
i'm gonna i'm gonna answer that
uh and i don't know if i will be
covering any more games uh
from the uh from the ultibox norway
championship i probably will
since uh i've tried this is this
actually the first time i'm
even trying to record a video since i
got back and uh
there don't seem to be any any issues oh
seems to be showing a bit of uh since we
seem to be showing a bit of scar there
uh but yeah it doesn't i don't seem to
be having any issues and like i said if
i said
any nonsense it has nothing to do with
my knowledge of chess
it has to do with anesthesia so yeah
that's uh that's the game uh hope you
guys enjoyed it i'm sure magnus didn't
but
you know at the end of one streak is
only the beginning of a new one
so we we have that to look forward to
and see where it takes us maybe two to
two hundred game streak
uh we'll see uh i would like to thank uh
jes de corte
uh garrett chandler uh savas mcleod is
uh rude van strahlen and vaselia stolius
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank all for watching and i
will see you soon
uh maybe continuing the coverage of this
uh tournament we'll see how it goes
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
do tell me uh what were the news uh like
in poland uh the next day after
do the defeated carlson uh see you soon
guys